all right one more and then I think I
got to do the book signing yes sir
what's your name my name is Jeff thanks
for thanks for taking my question sure
it was good stuff Mike liked what you
had to say Thanks um I'm talking about
when you're you're you're kind of
talking about what would you do for your
mother and then for your brother yeah
for a complete stranger yeah
I started a company called red monkey
foods we do gourmet seasonings and
spices so since I am a complete stranger
would you mind tweeting about it to your
900,000 friends good hustle I'm obsessed
with hustle right but see what I find
interesting is even though I just gave
it an really passionate talk you went
for the 19 year old dude move right you
try to close on our first transaction
and so that gives you a big [ __ ] no
but but I do love your swag and your
hustle and that's why you're sitting in
the room you go and hedge that you know
we're all the guys I told you my first
business was lemonade stands because I
really didn't want to tell you what it
really was my first business was really
four and a half I used to go to people's
yards rip their flowers out of their
yard ring their doorbell and sell it
back to them so unlike you I'm gangster
right
I'm sales I'm not up here mother Teresa
loved your 50 people I only remember you
forgot because it was an hour ago I only
do this because it's how business is
going to be done I'm only interested in
this stuff because it converts and it's
going to be the only thing against the
amount of noise that's going to be going
on in the world so what would have been
more interesting is when I talked about
you know the steak I was having for you
to like send and say hey I saw you in
500 and I'm sending you a little you
know spice that would go really great
with that and then I would say ah
good thank you economy tactic let me
retweet it but now you [ __ ] blew it
but there's a lot of other
but there's a lot of other pretty girls
out there so the next time you go into
the social media bar don't be a
douchebag roll deep thank you